first let's just try and clear this up
what's your advice to the public today
if they need to call 999 I want an
ambulance sent well it's to use their
Common Sense the the system will be
under very severe pressure today the
trade unions have refused to give
National exemptions in terms of all
life-threatening and emergency calls
they've said that they will prioritize
those but it'll be down to local
agreements with trust and indeed some
decisions taken in call centers so the
system will be under significant
pressure and therefore we were saying to
the public to exercise their common
sense in terms of what activities they
do be mindful of the fact that there are
those pressures on the system and should
local decisions are they not the best
ones to take rather than having a
national plan is that one of your
concerns there is no National
contingency plan in place is that your
job well the difficulty of putting
contingency measures in place is given
the uncertainty as to what exactly is
and is not being covered and the fact
that those decisions in some cases will
be taken on the day but it's also the
case that even what's referred to as
Category 3
urgent calls of often very serious as
well so we're doing all we can with NHS
colleagues so put in place contingency
measures we've got the Army we've got
volunteers we've got community services
we've got frail elderly services in
terms of people that might fall so
there's a range of measures from a
contingency perspective that we've been
putting in place but there's obviously
limits to what that can be done and
therefore it is down to the trade unions
in terms of what exemptions they provide
and the concern is particularly if
services are taken from the picket line
that adds further confusion on the day
and potentially delays responses as I
could State you said in your piece this
morning in the the telegraph that the
only way to resolve this is by talking
the unions wants to talk to you they
keep saying that but they want to talk
to you about pay so why wouldn't you do
that well we have a process in terms of
pay an independent process and we've
accepted the recommendations in full and
that looks at both the pressures on the
NHS and indeed at the Autumn statement
additional funding was targeted to the
NHS the chancellor allocated an extra
6.6 billion pounds to the NHS but he
also put in place the biggest ever
increase in Social care funding an extra
7.5 billion pounds over the next two
years and that recognizes particularly
for paramedics one of the biggest issues
that raised with me when I was talking
to ambulance staff on Sunday evening
actually what they said to me was more
important than pay was the frustration
around Handover delays at hospitals and
they're often caused by the delay in
getting patients out of Hospital who are
fit to be discharged that's why the
chancellor invested the extra 7.5
billion pounds in Social care an extra
two hundred thousand social care
packages so we're investing in the NHS
we're investing in uh social care and I
don't want to divert money from those
essential Services focused on patients
uh to overturn what has been an
independent process which has looked at
what is Affordable to the economy what
is Affordable to your viewers at a time
or cost of living pressure but also
recognizing the systems under very
severe pressure and we need to get that
extra investment into the NHS and into
social care uh we'll come back to some
of the points you make there in a moment
section of state but I just want to read
you um what's been said by the NHS
providers and NHS Confederation
yesterday they said that the fear of NHS
leaders is that the risk to patients is
only going to get worse with future
strikes plans that is unless the
government is able to reach agreement
with the trade unions to bring a swift
end to the dispute now that's not the
union saying that that's not nurses
saying that that is the NHS providers
and this is on the government on you to
come to an agreement well we have as I
say accepted in full the pay-per-view
body recommendations but that's in
addition to last year let me just let me
just interrupt you there sir I'm sorry
to do that but you always talk about the
pay review bodies and you know as well
as I do that the pay review body is not
always listened to back in 2014 the pay
review body recommended a one percent
increase in NHS pay that was rejected by
the now Chancellor Jeremy Hunt in 2018
police officers were recommended a pay
review increase of two percent that was
rejected as well so you can make a
decision to not listen into the
pay-per-view body why are you not doing
it in this instance and when we have
done that you you have been the first to
I'm sure to to criticize us for not
respecting the independence the
difference here is we have accepted
those recommendations in full because we
recognize the system coming out of the
pandemic has been under pressure so we
have accepted the recommendations in
full and that comes on top of last year
when the rest of the public sector had a
pay freeze we prioritized the NHS with
an extra three percent rise when many
other people were facing a pay free so
we have prioritized uh the NHS we've
accepted in full the independent pay
review bodies recommendations but we've
gone further and we've put an extra 6.6
billion pounds into the NHS and the
record funding into social care because
we recognize the shoe strains the NHS is
in as a consequence of the pandemic and
it's important that we focus on those
patient services to clear the the
backlogs in operations to address the
Handover delays to get this support into
primary care for GPS because that's
where the system is under most pressure
let me put let me put this to Mr Barkley
without having staff in the Health
Service because they're not being paid
they're not working in the right
conditions you won't be able to improve
those services and treatment outcomes
well it pay pay is a flat too I mean the
basic pay of a paramedic the average pay
of a paramedic is 34 300 but when you
add in overtime non-social ads that's an
extra 37 takes it up to 47
000 on top of that you get a 20 a fifth
going into pension as well so we have
listened to the recommendations of their
pay body on pay but pay is just one of a
number of factors we also look at the
fleet we're investing in more ambulances
we're putting more money into ambulance
trusts and extra 150 million pounds
we're also investing in call centers
because we've seen very significant
increases in pressure on the number of
calls that ambulance trusts are facing
so we put an extra 50 million pounds
into that and as well as that we
recognize there's a particular issue in
terms of the elderly those elderly uh
people that fall the need to get
services to them that's why we've been
working with Partners like Saint John's
ambulance an extra 30 million in to get
Saint John's ambulance targeting those
elderly fools so we're investing more in
the system we're doing that within the
context of an independent process that
looks at pay but it's also important
that we tackle some of these system
pressures particularly around social
care that's why we put the record
funding into that and that in turn has a
very big impact on paramedics that is
going to take a while to feed through as
you well know now you mentioned in in
the telegraph today that uh striking
workers are taking a conscious decision
to put patients at risk that's not
conciliatory language that's not going
to bring the two sides closers together
that's only going to harden uh the side
against you isn't it well it's just a
reflection of fact the trade unions have
chosen this time for the strike we saw
over the last week a 73 increase in flu
admissions to hospital we saw a 27
increase in covid emissions we've got
five times the normal prescribing rate
of prescriptions for antibiotics in
terms of strep a we've had a massive
increasing calls to 111 up by more than
a third we've got an increase in calls
to 999 over the last month of 15 so the
system is facing very significant
pressures as a result of flu of covid of
strep a and it's at this time that trade
unionism not only chosen to strike but
have refused to put in place National
exemptions to say they will cover all of
the life-threatening and emergency cat
one cat two calls that in turn makes the
contingency measures much more difficult
to play and I'm sure the Unions would
say that they're not putting patients at
risk you're actually putting patients at
risk by not willing not being willing to
discuss their pay requests now this has
been sold in Scotland by meeting the pay
requests of uh striking staff there
would the government go to something
like that seven and a half percent for
nurses to try and resolve these strikes
one of the big misconceptions about the
the deal in Scotland and incidentally
the GMB were opposed to the deal in
Scotland they're one of the trade unions
that are striking but it wasn't simply
seven and a half percent if you add in
all the other measures in terms of
reducing hours extra annual leave
changes to the way over time is address
protected learning time actually the
cost of that is much more significant
and as I say one of the trade unions has
rejected that as well but what we want
to do is focus on patience get that
investment into the NHS into social Care
address the blockage there are patients
that are ready to leave Hospital who is
not in their interest to stay so get
that social care and flow working that
is what we prioritized and we've done
that whilst also listening to what is an
independent process around the
pay-per-view bodies we've accepted those
recommendations in full and that builds
on the extra three percent we awarded
last year at a time when other public
sector workers face to freeze
okay Steve Barkley uh thanks for being
with us